okay we're like so back
we are it's awesome we love the 80s and
we have a couple here who love the 80s
so much they turned it into a business
please welcome the owners of rusty's ice
cream shop in fort wayne indiana
boyfriend and girlfriend team rusty
amaran and angela lanning
welcome
thank you um you guys look great rusty
where did you come up with the idea for
an 80s themed ice cream shop well i love
ice cream
and i love the 80s
uh so i we we're going to we started
with an ice cream truck and i thought if
we're going to do this i'm going to do
it the way disney would if disney had an
ice cream truck i would it would be
themed it would be immaculate it would
be interactive it'd be fun it'd be
entertaining and angela i know you've
been delivering ice cream around the
community during the pandemic yeah so we
got stir crazy like everybody else did
during the pandemic and everybody was
kind of afraid to go
out and about so
we were like you know what let's just
let's take the ice cream truck out let's
see if it works
social distance ice cream social and so
we cruise around neighborhoods
with the music it's not like it's not
like the old school ice cream truck yeah
yeah right and by the way i just want to
mention to everybody you are giving the
ice cream out for free sometimes yeah
yeah
come on
yeah halloween last year everybody was
still a little
like scared so we just yeah during
during the pandemic we said let's just
let's just do this and be normal because
we don't know if anybody's going to come
out you can drive around the
neighborhood and people just may look at
you through the window like children of
the corn 80s reference
so okay what has been the most
challenging part of having the small
business in the last few years i don't
know if you heard there was a pandemic
did you hear about that yes
just as we were moving from
transitioning from an ice cream truck to
an ice cream shop we went into brick and
mortar themed in the 80s and do it right
rock it out uh that's when it the the
economy tank that's when we had a
location picked out
we were trying to figure out design
construction all of that i really
appreciate your passion
and your knowledge and your ability to
pivot and supporting small businesses is
something we're really passionate about
here on the show and i really want you
to meet someone she's an entrepreneur
and an investor and a best-selling
author
this woman whoa i can't believe she's
here please welcome kim purrell
hi guys
um kim i just want to set up your cv um
a little bit um will you quickly tell us
about your journey and how you sort of
grew your business
yeah first i want to say i love the 80s
and
i love ice cream so i congratulations
it's amazing what you guys done and your
story is so inspiring and
like you i started you know
during a crisis and i started my kitchen
table
and it is it was a struggle like it's
never easy to become an entrepreneur and
it's amazing and inspiring to see you
guys make that jump into
entrepreneurship during a really hard
time and you know when i i've been
through it like it's been a struggle i
started at my kitchen and you know i've
been it's a roller coaster from an
entrepreneurial standpoint and
my grandma made a bet on me
and she gave me ten thousand dollars
when i started my first company and wow
it was just such a blessing and i
love what you guys are doing i'm so
passionate about entrepreneurship and
supporting small businesses and i would
first love to mentor you guys on your
journey thank you
[Applause]
skip the line that the ice cream line
that is and i would also love
to gift you
thousand dollars
thank you thank you thank you
um
i also because kim is so humble and i so
appreciate that um how much did you end
up selling your company for him
yes i actually sold it twice so the last
time i spoke for 235 million
that's more right yes wow
so the reason i want to say that is not
to be braggadocious as they would say in
the 80s it's to say that kim you have
true knowledge of how to take money
um
that's invested in you by someone and
and turn it into something this is not
just money
your wisdom which also everybody can get
because kim has a new book called jump
dare to do what scares you in business
and life
we can all learn a lot from kim
thank you drew i'm so excited to just
pay it forward and help others make
those life-changing leaps and it's so
inspiring to see what you guys are doing
and i can't wait to share that journey
with you thank you so much scooping
right we got to start scooping yes
exactly amazing it's not just the money
it's the experience and the wisdom to me
that's the potent combination of doing
this with you kim so i'm so
[Applause]
her new grateful dare to do what scares
you in business and in life what a great
title don't we all need to face those
fears and that's available november 16th
i will be like
yeah right
um
oh my gosh wow the yellow doors are
doing it again i wonder what decade
they're gonna take us to next i don't
know but i'm intrigued
[Music]
you